[Music]
yeah so like you mentioned the
co-founder at next-gen vests and a
research here at Columbia focus in
computational neuroscience and deep
learning and what I'm going to be
talking through today is how to scale
human advice using deep learning
specifically in the context of chatbots
and we're not just gonna be talking
about regular chat BOTS but where could
it be talking about human powered chat
BOTS and I'll explain what that means
and a brief agenda of what we're talking
about today is first I'm gonna discuss
how next-gen vus is helping solve the
student loan crisis and then next we're
gonna talk about the business
motivations about the particular
approach that we chose then we'll talk
about the state of the art of chatbots
and kind of bring you up to speed on the
current research and what we sent and
then we'll talk through the
implementation of our particular chatbot
talk through the results and then future
directions for it my goal is for you to
walk away today knowing how to do this
in your own company and how do you sleep
learning to maybe scale some sort of
advice that you're trying to generate
for your own clients so what is next-gen
vez we basically help neck Gen Z
navigate the student loan process over
SMS and as a result of the past year
we've helped over 44,000 students access
about 39 million dollars in aid and what
that means is we're helping students
kind of fill out their FAFSA and figure
out how to do the financial aid process
so show of hands who here has taken out
student loans so most people here and
I'm sure you've gone through that
process it's extremely confusing I went
through it when I was in high school and
I did it without a lot of guidance so I
had maybe two guidance counselor's in my
school in Florida with about 5,000
students and so I wasn't on so I left
the Navy and came to New York that I
went through that same process to come
to Columbia but I realized this was a
huge problem that I wanted to help solve
and so despite the average college
student graduating with about $37,000 of
debt we leave about 2.7 billion dollars
in unclaimed financial aid and the
reason for that is because the forms are
extremely confusing and to have zero
guidance or in that process so who our
money mentors this is our solution to
the problem so we take train college
students and we augment them with
technology to help our users basically
navigate this process
and so what that looks like is will go
into your high school we'll give you a
presentation and during that process
you'll text into our system and you'll
be paired immediately with the money
mentor and you can think of them like
your guidance counselor from then on
their help you with anything financial
related with their college admissions
process or the application process you
can call them at 7:00 a.m. 10:00 p.m.
doesn't matter they're always there and
just to give you a little bit
perspective we have about 16 part-time
honey mentors and we're servicing about
44,000 students when we started this we
had about 80 of them and we've automated
a lot of the things that they were doing
now and so we're able to kind of reduce
that to 16 so kind of motivation for why
we did what we did is we have one money
mentor that's servicing roughly 50
students and this is just kind of like a
ballpark figure of what I'm going to
talk about in terms of like what happens
when they have too many students right
and so let's say that someone has 50
students that they're servicing at any
one time
those students are normally happy and we
can get to those responses and have a
deep and engaging conversation easily
but as soon as we go to maybe about a
hundred then that person's kind of
efficiency goes down and obviously this
will Plateau at some point where
basically we're not servicing anyone
well and so any advice that you get as
any of those students at that point is
gonna be pretty bad and kind of shallow
and so what happens is we have money
mentors who are collapsing during that
and this is not good for us because we
need to keep these highly trained
college students in our platform and so
we have to play this kind of balance of
how many people can we put on the
platform or not and we we do a lot of
kind of like you can think about it like
load balancing in terms of like
balancing out our engagement strategy
with people who are on the platform
right so when there's no one on there
we'll use we have a reinforcement
learning based algorithm that will
basically try to engage people using
particular messages highly less likely
to engage them as a result we build
deeper conversations but that means that
we can't have as many people on at the
same time so we have this kind of like
scaling problem as we do our job more
efficiently so we take an approach
called human first AI and so everyone
you know past few years have been
talking about
Xai or like these other chat BOTS who
are basically
taking the approach of taking a bot and
trying to humanize it what we're doing
is going the opposite way we're taking a
human and basically automating a lot of
the parts that are repetitive for them
and basically augmenting them so we can
do their job more efficiently so we can
get at the human element of the
conversation which is actually caring
about that student and helping them
through this process so some of the
things I money mentor my two are like
match you for scholarships give you
advice on colleges etc a lot of those
things we can actually automate and help
them do those more efficiently so here's
an example conversation from our chat UI
and on the right you have the money
mentor and then on the left you have a
student and what happens is we have
these four suggested responses for that
money mentor and that's in the context
of this conversation so this is
obviously a cherry-picked example and if
you want to see more of these actual
conversations you can come to office
hours after me sorry after the chat and
I'll show you all the live demo with all
the actual messages going through and
what they are so here you can see that
they're talking about I guess they're
just having a regular chat about like
how are your classes going like this is
hard to read here and basically this
person ends with yeah I'm in an English
class and an econ class and they're just
basically describing some classes and so
some of the responses that we have are
okay oh yeah that sounds like senior
year you know excited about any of your
classes so that's pretty relevant maybe
maybe the last part of that sentence
isn't super relevant but for the most
part of the first message would kind of
apply but most most likely the second
one would be better so that's okay lol
did you like those classes so the
messages that are suggested here are in
the language of the user with
grammatical errors kind of lol and all
these like heuristics that high school
students are using to speak right now so
it's a design in a way that the money
mentor can access these suggestions and
send those edit them or send them right
but they're never automated initially
actually they're never automated because
we want people to to choose and by
people I made our money mentors to
choose what they're going to send to the
students and so before we get into how
we actually made that happen I want to
talk about kind of the current state of
chatbots and four different ways which
you could go about implementing some of
these and so the first one is a template
based chat
and you can think about these as a kind
of if and then that rule where you can
generate a rule for a particular case
and then augment it with some sort of
classifier to help you expand that rule
to more use cases so one example is if
you go on your computer you go into
Emacs and you type in that sequence
you'll actually load this program called
Eliza and Eliza is a program that was
developed by psychologists I think in
1966 and you can ask your kind of this
templated question so you say I am X and
then we'll return with did you come to
me because you are whatever so I could
have said I'm tired and did you come to
me because you're tired and so on and so
this is kind of like one of the earlier
implementations of this and so the brief
overview of how that happens is let's
say you have a user and they text in the
sentence hi you're gonna basically
classify that you might have like a
bunch of different classes this one
happens to be greeting once you've made
that classification through your
favorite classifier then you can go and
just pick a response that matches that
bucket and you can say okay this is a
greeting so I'm going to pick one of
those and send that to that person
that's great
and here's some ApS I can actually help
you do this right and so can't really
see here but this is from an API that
used to be called API that AI they've
just renamed but you can go under and
basically on the Left what you would
have is something like hey what's the
weather in San Francisco it will detect
those two entities and then you have
kind of this mapping into rules I can go
to reply to that and they'll be able to
kind of match that as host messages are
happening so you can pay for this or I
think good to have a free version but
you basically have a bot running in a
few minutes tops and I think that slides
will be available after so you can see
the links to all this so some of the
pros for this particular approach are
that it's obviously easy to implement so
you can get up and running maybe within
an hour thirty minutes and there's a ton
of pre-built classifiers SK learn the
api's have them you can just kind of get
your model to a fast MVP some of the
cons are obviously that it's real
expensive to create these rules because
you have to have human labor do it and
you're not going to be able to craft
every single possible case that comes
through your chats
so these are the chats when you engage
with like a customer service they sound
a little bit robotic and if you don't
say the exact thing that they want
you're not going to get anywhere
so some references to some of the
research around this the first one was
Eliza bot byways embalm 1966 and you can
look through their papers after but I
also put the links to the two API so
with that AI and API that AI it's not
called dialog flow so you can go there
and kind of experiment with that so the
next type of models that you can build
our retrieval based models and so the
content the concept is very simple you
basically have a context and giving that
context you just select the response
that matches that context right and
these models can get as complicated or
as simple as you want them basically you
can think about them as google smart
reply here where you have an email and
you will have that email will be the
context and then the responses that are
down here are actually taken from a set
of possible responses and they're only
showing you maybe the top three that are
most relevant the other ones are kind of
yeah not really shown here and the way
you can think about this abstract leus
you have some sort of context and you're
going to run it through some model
whatever that could be a neural network
SVM whatever you want and then that's
going to output some sort of probability
distribution for that particular
response given the context and in our
case those error messages and you're
going to select the two with the highest
or K highest with probability whatever
and send those back to the user ask the
most relevant responses so the pros for
this type of model is that you're not
going to get some rogue bots on Twitter
that's racist or whatever because you
have a curated list of responses if you
want poorly written responses you can
put them in your responses so we want
responses to have grammatical errors and
kind of like high school language so
we'll actually put those in there to
sound like humans right and next if you
use steep learning you can use end to
end training for this which means you
don't have to handcraft your features do
any feature selection you could to try
to get it to work a little bit better
but generally the you know kind of deep
learning approach would be deep end to
end training for what
model you want the problem is if you get
into kind of if you dig into the
research you'll notice that it's really
hard to model long conversations after
maybe a few turns and a turn being where
I ask you something you reply something
back after a few turns you'll kind of go
into this hole of questions where it'll
be like you know like who are you what
are you doing and so on and so you can
get into really complex models and it's
going to be a little bit hard to to kind
of provide that versity to responses so
if you saw in the Google reply let's say
that I asked you hey let's have coffee
next Monday
you can have three reply so it could be
like yes it sounds great Monday's great
or like cool that's awesome but maybe
you want something with more orthogonal
where you have okay actually - so it
works better
hey monday is great or hey I actually
can't do that time whatever some
responses actually add more direction to
some some possible things that you
actually wanted to say the next version
of this is kind of like to sex your
models that have been around you know
they've been getting a lot of publicity
in the media lately especially last year
and these are sequence of sequence
models and these are basically two
recurrent networks where you have one
encoder network that takes some sort of
input that goes through one network
output to an encoding vector that vector
goes into a decoding network and that
eye puts a sequence step by step to
generate a response and so what that
looks like is this is just this happens
to be an LS TM recurrent network but
this recurrent network is taking this
incoming email are you free tomorrow
it's gonna run it through the network
going to put out an encoding vector this
is literally like 1 by 500 or however
many dimensions you want at the end
you're going to feed that into a decoder
and that's going to generate these
responses one step at a time until it
runs until that end token representation
for that particular sentence at which
point you know you can send that
response and obviously you can strain
this whole thing into end so it's a lot
simpler to deal with and so you've seen
this in language to language translation
there have been if you use Google right
now and your phone a lot of these these
models were like basically ass of like
mid last year suddenly it started
working magically that's because of
these models so this is from a Stanford
class just to zero si and you can Google
class and it's an amazing kind of
research with tensorflow I think it's
called but basically you can see some of
these models here where you know the
human saying hey you're a monster you're
kind of replying with yeah I am
the models are playing with I am then
you're kind of saying random things to
try to get it to say things but if you
see at the end you end up kind of
getting into a Q&A system at the Q&A
problem so here is you can see this
better but you'll say something like
what do you need yeah I need your help
okay what do you want and when you gets
into that Parshin of like what do you
want what do you do in and so on it'll
just kind of go back and forth in this
question so there's a lot of research
right now and how to get it out of that
and some of the research that they're
proposing is basically building out your
loss function in specific ways where you
take a sum of different parts to promote
maybe diversity in one component to
promote maybe like a different goal and
another component and when you add that
up your network learns to optimize over
those different parts and will actually
start maybe giving you longer turn so
maybe two or three turns so so impress
and cons for this particular approach
you get excellent modeling for the
sequences so our intents are amazing
kind of taking the sequence order into
account when you're doing something is
supposed to like a bag of where it's
approach and you can learn complex
representations of your sequences and by
using an RNN you basically avoid the
fixed size problem of putting things
into a regular neural network or you
have to know the input size however it's
really hard to model long term
dependencies and a lot of research
recently has started to you something
called attention where basically it
looks back into the network and says oh
actually maybe you know because what
you're expecting that work to do is to
encode everything into that last vector
but by using attention what you're
saying is hey maybe you want the first
word in that sentence to be actually
weighed heavier than everything else in
order to give you better predictions
down the road and so the model obviously
can is free to output whatever it wants
which can be considered a con if your
network goes wild
but they'll collapse or longer
conversations so here are some research
covering kind of the latest in in this
particular space and I'll put you can
look at this later but
I think some of the interesting ones I
put at the top so then coder decoder RNN
model Cho is one of the guys who
invented the sequence of sequence along
with a sus cover and so that model came
out I want to say mid 2014 and they'd
been expanding it since come on yeah
2014 so they're just like recently
started working really well and then I
guess the next one is reinforcement
learning and the reinforcement learning
can actually be applied to any of these
but I want to treat us its own subject
because you can think about it like
another layer on top of a model but what
is reinforcement learning in general
it's basically you're trying to learn a
recipe for what action to take given a
state of the world so you can think
about this in this in this context so
this is a deep mind model and this model
was trained to basically try to do
parkour
and what it's doing it's saying all
you're telling it is I want you to get
to the end of this you're not telling it
how so the model has to learn that in
order to move it needs to like stand up
and in order to run it needs to move its
feet and maybe learns to move its hand
in a weird way so it you're by not
giving the specific rules the model has
the freedom to basically decide what the
most optimal path is and it'll start
basically optimizing that so deep go is
based on reinforcement learning so
alphago and there's a lot of work at
open AI and deep mind specifically
around this so what is like how do we
break up this reinforcement learning
strategy so we have three components to
it right so you have an agent and I'm
talking about reinforcement learning
you're not deep reinforcement learning
right now so we'll make that distinction
in a little bit but basically you have
this agent and this agent lives in this
world and it can be a game or whatever
and you kind of have to figure out how
to frame your problem into this like
contra the world and how to navigate
that world and all you're trying to do
is learn this policy this policy is like
a map of how to navigate that so it's
saying look when I'm in this place I'm
going to take these sequence of moves
that's going to get you to the goal or
whatever and I want to just comment that
these these are slides from the UC
Berkeley deep reinforcement learning
boot camp so I was there at this summer
and I thought these were like maybe some
of the best slides to kind of explain a
lot of this concept these concepts
and how you're learning this policy is
basically by optimizing this particular
function it's called the optimal value
function and you can think about this as
like a sum of discount or rewards when
starting at some point and then acting
acting optimally from there so you're
here you're going to act the best way
given your current policy and that's
going to give you this particular result
and so this is a question I'm not gonna
go too much into detail I'm just gonna
briefly talk about the parts of it but
you're just going to kind of go over
every single time step and during that
time step we're going to look at the
reward that you're going to gain by
going from this state to the next state
given a particular action that's that
according to your policy so whatever
policy you have and then you're going to
discount that over the long run using
some sort of discount right because you
don't want actions in the future to
affect you too much because they're a
little bit more uncertain so you
actually want to just take more into
consideration of what you have these are
obviously hyper parameters that you can
mess with and you're just kind of
maximizes in the long run and so when
you talk about deep reinforcement
learning what you're saying is that
you're actually going to replace that
agent with a neural network and the way
we can think about it in our case is
let's say we have a chat we can think
about the chat as a current state of the
world and so all the messages are that
led up to that and the conversation to
this state to this point is kind of
snapshot at netzer State and then every
message that we could send to that user
that's going to be a particular action
and so we're going to basically design a
reward function that's going to maximize
something in our case its value and
depth of conversation and we model that
through a particular formula that's
going to send this particular message to
that user to maximize over those things
so if we take our model that we had
before where we had a context you can
basically just replace a context with
the state and then replace your model
with an agent which is going to be
computing the policy and instead of
outputting probabilities you're actually
going to actually output the rewards for
that particular state given your
particular policy and you're going to
pick the K highest we will rewards and
those are the messages that you're going
to send so here's an excerpt from one of
the papers and this is I believe this is
a team at Stanford so if your giraffes
key is
a big researcher and I know P at
Stanford right now and here's some
examples of kind of how this works and
so you can see some of the same issues
kind of starting to come up in terms of
I don't know what you're talking about
and kind of ending in this question and
I'm assuming a lot of the training data
that they're using has a lot of these
questions so it's kind of like learning
to pick that up so you've ever done
anything with image and that for example
there are a lot of dogs on there so you
might get a lot of a lot of features
that are related to that so it's a
little bit similar here and so the kind
of the two most relevant papers that I
think are in this particular research
are both actually from that group and
they're they're just basically exploring
the the relationship between sequence of
sequence models and apply and
reinforcement learning to them so you
can take this reinforcement learning and
apply to any model that you want as long
as you're kind of driving those
decisions using your particular reward
function so how do we actually build our
BOTS we basically we call it ngv because
our companies ngv so so this actually
this particular implementation is based
on this paper by Google it's called the
Fisher natural language response
suggestion for smart reply and you know
this as smart reply on your phone right
now so this paper came out I want to say
May 2017 and there was a previous
version they use Alice TMS but then they
realized that they couldn't scale and
they were really expensive to train and
so they actually came up with a separate
version different model which I'll talk
about right now that basically helps
scale better and actually performs a lot
better maybe not in the particular
metrics of objective evaluation but
actually when you look at click-through
rates which is actually what matters how
often are people actually using your
suggestions they saw 700 percent
improvement by using these particular
models as opposed to the Alice TM models
so what that looks like well for us
we're obviously not Google because we
don't have emails we're actually using
chat so we modified this to work on
chats as opposed to emails and it's a
slightly different problem I'm assuming
that they're taken into account more
than just your last email but we're
looking at our whole chat history which
could be 50 to 100 different messages
and as a start-up we don't have 300
million mmm
we have tops three million text messages
and basically anytime that we've sent a
response we can treat that as an XY
example right so an overview of how we
actually build the model I just want to
highlight that step one it's very
important this is how you get the
relationship modeling because we're not
using LS CMS so you're basically gonna
generate engrams you can use by trigrams
I think we use up to throw trigrams but
you're actually going to compute
embeddings on those trigrams and by
grams and that's going to give you the
modeling power for the for the word
ordering and it's not doesn't work as
great as lc/ms in that context but the
trade-off is very marginal wouldn't in
practice in terms of learning the
embeddings you actually we actually
learn the benning's in the network so we
don't load them with pre-trained
embeddings and if you have any questions
about any of this feel free to come to
office hours and I can explain whatever
parts you guys are missing so what we're
gonna actually do is do two different
things so we're going to take the
context which is the chat we're gonna
run it through the network one side of
the network that's going to give us a
vector representation and encoding for
that and we're going to take a response
for that chat and run it through another
side of the network that's going to give
us another encoding for that and we're
going to multiply those together to
maximize the dot product and that's
going to be our loss function do an
inference what we're going to do is give
it a new chat we're going to encode that
chat and for a precomputed set of
responses so before you do inference
you've taken all your responses and
precomputed all those vectors all you
have to do is do a matrix multiply
against all those I'm finding once I
have the highest score and then return
those so what does that look like is we
have our chat we're going to treat that
as our context here I'm just showing the
text message but in reality you're going
to turn these into numbers and the
numbers are going to map to specific
index in your embedding matrix and it's
not going to be just words it's going to
be by grants and trigrams so just want
to stress like because it won't work if
you don't do that
then we're going to take that response
as their Y and we're gonna do the same
process and we I think we use 50 for our
sequence length so you can you you
basically have to you know obviously
some messages aren't just 50 character
50 words long they're maybe longer
we tried this is something you have to
search over in your hyper parameter
optimization you can go to 150 50
whatever its affects the length of
training and then the efficiency of it
and if you don't have let's say you have
a sentence it's like hey hello how are
you by using a sentence that's 50 long
the rest are just zeros and you're gonna
pad those with zeros to make everything
the same length so just an overview of
how we're going to actually think
through this model is like I mentioned
you have your x and y we have our data
which is basically context each X and
the response for that context each y and
we're going to like I said run your X
through a model through one network and
then put in our particular case we're
using a three layer dense network and
this is the exact model that they use in
their paper and the same the same model
not literally the same but the same
architecture we're going to run the
response through there and get another
encoding vector then we're going to take
those do a dot product we're gonna
compute a score between a particular
context and that particular response and
that's going to give us a scalar value
for each pair and just a brief overview
here so each one of these blocks has two
layers after the dense once called a
batch normal to dropout
these are regularization layers
Batchelor helps stabilize gradients
flowing through the network and the
dropout layers help you with overfitting
so if you want to go into the theory and
talk about that more you can come to
office hours so we're trying to rank the
responses and we're basically going to
do this through this distribution and
it's basically we're going to
approximate this through softmax output
on the network and what we're going to
do is use a neural network to estimate
the probability scores up there so you
have the probability of this particular
context occurring with this response
divided by the probability of this
context and all the responses and you
sum those up right so that's really
expensive to actually do and so like any
time that we're trying to estimate the
posterior we're actually going to sorry
anytime they were actually trying to
calculate the posterior we're not
actually going to do that some we're
actually going to estimate it and so the
way we're going to do that is through
something called negative sampling
so there's a lot of literature on this
but I just want to explain it very
briefly because it's a key part of
making this work and negative sampling
you can think about it like you take a
batch of data let's say you have 50
items in your batch and you're going to
treat all of them as wrong except one
which is where the I and the J meats and
so that's saying okay for example 1 and
response 1 that's correct
for example 1 and every other why that's
wrong right and so what that looks like
is when you compute that score at the
end for each particular pair we're going
to say this diagonal is correct and
everything else is wrong for that
particular row and so just to highlight
that and like bring that point home you
take that row of this is one particular
example so this is maybe your first X Y
pair you're going to say ok this is at
the top so that the diagonal starts on
the left this is correct everything else
is wrong and you're just going to
compute an estimate doing that and this
is basically like a very quick brief
summary of negative sampling and what
we're actually going to end up training
over is once we have this estimate we're
actually going to minimize the we're
going to approximate the negative log
likelihood so we're just going to take
the log of this and basically code this
part up as a neural that's a loss
function for the Newell Network and this
this bottom equation here I mean it
looks ugly but it's really just two
terms on the left you have a score and
the right you have the sum of all the
other scores and just taking the MSE of
that so you can't see this but this is
code but we blew it up so this is our
implementation of negative sampling so
what I did here was I took a generate
the case we can see that matrix here
this is the scoring matrix and sorry
I'll go back so all you're doing is the
context channel is the output of a
network the context Network and then the
utterance utterance channel is the
output of the other network and we're
going to just take the multiplication
then we're going to generate these
scores then from there we're going to
pull out the diagonal and then we're
just going to reshape that into a 1 by
the responses sorry responses by 1
vector that's going to be our s so it's
going to be the left term on the MSC at
the end
and then you're going to take the row
and you're just gonna sum across the
rows right and that's going to give you
another vector and you're just going to
do the MMSE of those two and that's
basically what you're optimizing over so
when you're do an inference for this
what you're going to do is basically
take all of yours possible responses and
run them through the network to
pre-compute those encoding vectors and
you're going to save those so it's this
off line and that's going to make
inference pretty much real-time on
whatever you're running we actually do
this over 500,000 messages so I want to
say and it takes us like 10 milliseconds
tops on a like regular ec2 - core CPU
and the training is all done in GPUs but
the inference is actually done in CPUs
and so when you get a context and you
chat you're gonna run it through the
network that's going to give you an
encoding vector for that and they're
just going to take the dot product
between all of these and that's going to
give you this course and you're going to
generate you're going to return to NK
highest which in this case would be 3
for this particular message we do four
for our chats so how did our model
actually do well it's hard because we're
actually using a paper from like two
months ago or three months ago and there
also isn't any implementation of this
anywhere so we have our own
implementation in which are actually
gonna open source today and I'll give
you the look at hub link at the end of
this but basically we had to basically
use a method called recall at K so
recall at K is think about it like a
guessing game you have ten cards you
have to pick one of those right if your
K equals one you get one chance of
getting the card right and that's
basically how we going to evaluate the
network so on the paper they do K at 1
and K at to basically saying okay you
get one chance you're gonna get it right
if you have 10 items and you get 10
chances you have a hundred percent
accuracy obviously because you can just
pick all of them so when we do it for
our particular case we have five
responses you're going to say okay which
one's the best of these you're going to
pick one you get 0 for that the network
and so you're going to when you actually
get the right one then you get a point
so you're happy right so how do we do
for our Ricola k equals 1 we actually
got 62 percents
and you're like great what does that
mean so what that means is that we're a
little bit in the ballpark because they
got 52% on their paper obviously we're
not doing email so it's not a strictly
fair comparison at all
but it's really hard to gauge where you
are when something's like being
developed and it's like at the state of
the art and so this is kind of one
example what really counts for us is
conversion rates right and so when we've
rolled this hat I hasn't been out long
enough to be able to actually give you
like a solid number on that but what I'm
looking at is from all the messages that
we've suggested how many times were
those actually used without any
modification because as we iterate on it
that's actually what I'm going to be
basing the success of new models as we
continue to deploy them to see which
ones actually work better so I can just
a be test train new models will we do
this we have local GPUs at our office so
we'll train them there and then just do
the nightly deployments and a/b test
them and then figure out like what's
converting better
so where we going in the future I mean
this is an active area of research so
we're hoping to participate in in that
and publish them some papers on this but
we basically are working on this kind of
orthogonal problem as well so when you
have this response let's do Monday
Monday works etc we actually want to say
other responses that could also be
possible that don't already mean the
same thing we also want to add a
reinforcement layer on top of this so
you could basically we've already
started doing part of this you can see
for this particular message here we've
computer and expected reward and that's
a function of kind of the value that
we're going to deliver to that user and
the depth of a conversation and some
combination of that and so we want to
actually we don't were not we're doing
this for a ring for re-engagement
strategy but not for our chat bot and so
we actually want to take this and apply
that same concept on it and start
driving the conversations more so if
you're actually going to do this I want
to give you some actual tips that will
help you because it's really if you ever
try to do in your own network stuff like
you read about it you download the code
and you're like this doesn't work so a
lot of it is because you're hyper
parameters and I think the biggest one
is you're learning right so if you have
a network that isn't outputting anything
just increment it by 10 or divided by 10
a bunch of times until you get to the
right range but here
a good range I will actually start
working for you so we we already
pre-configured the one and github to
give you a fairly good accuracy on this
I didn't do a rigorous grid search or a
random search over it but I give you
some pretty good parameters on there so
next is learning the embedding so a lot
of people say hey glowed like a word to
vac embedding or globe globe I don't
know you say that into the network but
it practical actually makes a little bit
of mix little difference and it's like a
lot of work to generate those embeddings
if you're using by Gramps and trigrams
so I would suggest learning them in the
network you're gonna have to fine-tune
those embeddings that you load anyways
which means that you're gonna take the
words effect load into the network and
then they're what's going to change
those weights and so you're just kind of
modifying those anyways and you want to
experiment with averaging so when we're
inputting a sequence into the network
we're actually importing for each word a
vector that represents that embedding
for that particular word but an LST M
would be able to kind of merge those
into one vector but in this case we
can't do that so we have to either sum
them all up or take an average and so in
our in the paper they actually use a sum
but in our in our experimentation at
least for our context an average
actually worked a lot better so I would
experiment between those given your
particular use case and this refers to
the optimizer that you want to use so
we're all familiar with stochastic
gradient descent so SGD in the deep
learning world you have a bunch of other
ones adam rmsprop ad a grad whatever
adam is maybe the most popular one that
one is because it adjusts with the the
learning rate automatically asks the
velocity of your learning decreases
however there's a lot of research in the
past like six months that basically is
showing that like actually if you just
use s ug correctly you get better
results so I would just take that with
the grain of salt but we use Adam for
everything and where you actually turned
to implement this you can you can either
use a tensor flow sampled softmax which
will give you kind of the same result
but if you're actually going to do this
you don't actually want to use this
function call it or do you want to use
this function called reduce law log some
X because if you actually try to put the
exponent and then the log of that like
you're going to overflow and you're not
going to learn anything so tensorflow
has this trick and to have a
while that works but they basically just
cap it at something so just to summarize
our impact
we've helped 44,000 students access 39
million dollars in aid and our goal is
to help them access 200 million more and
the way we've done that is through
scaling through these methods based on
deep learning and reinforcement learning
and like I said we're taking a human
first AI approach because we believe
that in order to scale the current state
of the art for AI you actually have to
draw you have to have humans driving
that and you can't necessarily go the
other way you can't take a bot and
humanize it we think it's easier to take
a human and make him smarter and
actually in the broader theme of AI I'd
like to believe that we're actually
making humanity smarter as opposed to
replacing people's jobs so this is
actually the link to our implementation
so you can get this on the slides I
don't think there's another one out
there there's I think one from last year
for the Ellis TM model but this one
works and it's all in tensor flow so
it's easier to kind of mess around with
I'm not gonna demo you have to come to
office hours for that and so I just want
to quickly thank the people who helped
me put this presentation together so my
co-founder Kelly and our CEO grace her
director of design Sachin our senior
back in engineer who actually deployed
this to AWS and then Mitchell our front
engineer who build the interface or who
is our front engineer so he builds
interfaces with our products so I just
want to remind everyone we're using the
state of the art technology to actually
help thousands of students access
education so we're solving a real
problem and we are hiring so if you're
looking to solve actual problems that
matter using really cool technology come
talk to me after any questions
I guess I have time for questions sir
I may have misunderstood this but you
mentioned that the way at inference time
you generate a pre computed list of
responses and then you pick the top key
how do you generate the how do you get
the P computed responses yeah so for
inference you take every possible
response you could have in our case it's
every time we've sent a message back
right and so we're going to take those
through the network that's already
trained and we're going to take we're
gonna snap off that arm for the encoder
for the responses and we're just going
to run each one of those responses
through that network that's going to
give us that and in an encoding and
we're gonna save that vector we're gonna
just save those into I don't know like
an array or whatever and then you when
you do an inference you load that into
memory or you can use spark or whatever
you want and basically just run through
the matrix multiplication for that does
that answer your question it's up to you
so for air in our case it's 500,000
because it saw the possible responses
and then the the width of that vector is
however big your last layer and that
neural network is in our case reason 500
so it's 500,000 by 500 but that's a high
performer for your case it might be 200
100 whatever it is on the github is 500
[Music]